vous dire on va faire une cabine à grand
bluff
ensemble avec patrick avec la cabine qui
est là venez me rejoindre et il y a
c'est une cabine un petit peu spécial
aujourd'hui puisqu'il ya patrick
sébastien bon feeling beaucoup vous
allez voir première cabine
elie vous allez regarder ce que vous
voyez de ryan je vous dis ce que je vois
voilà exactement
et moi je vais dire mais c'est la vérité
ce que je vais pas je sais pas je ne
sais pas où ils vont dire si qui dit la
vérité
attention c'est parti ok donc là je vois
renault en train de faire la vidange de
sa renault au nom traduit en effet la
vidange de sa renault
moi je vous dire je vois florent pagny
qui est avec une plante et qui chante ma
liberté de planter et noémie monopoly à
dire et bien elie
[Musique]
c'est fou le yoga question c'est un
sosie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci d'être là en tout cas est franchie
à tous c'est top
et bien est ce que tu vois deuxième cas
minable moi je vois francis cabrel pas
qui fait quoi
il est en train de répéter les sardines
d'accord et lis tu veux voir un truc 1 à
10 moi je vois pas un homme je vois une
femme oui bah ouais y'a un problème ça
va toi la moustache va-t-on non je vois
nabila qui lit un livre je vois maître
gims qui fait de la gym donc mettre
régime qui fait de la gym zen roi
richard ii nîmes ça va être long métrage
in that robbie bach labeda rickard
wallin artistes hélène francis cabrel
est maître gims ou alors qu'il a comme
on me l'a dit un vrai gamin et bien
regardez c'était
merci m
[Musique]
fait marquant
c'est nos gars franchement c'est le cas
c'est la personne qui arrive actifs et
bercy et merci d'être là je vois tu vois
je vois moi ouais je vois patrick
sébastien qui manger une choucroute avec
des sardines encore elie ok moi je vois
michel drucker way qui [ __ ] dans un
plat de semoule occupée d'al dans la
souris dalle dans la semoule mais chaque
week end historique lors qu'il peut
vendre le riz caire un traitement ccc de
la choucroute spa de la sainteté de la
semoule
j'en veux dire je crois moi je vois
fabio salsa le coiffeur qui fabbro shing
un sosie de valérie bénaïm away
alors à vos copains drucker drucker a
loupé un truc c'est le single c'était
patrick sébastien
cher
[Musique]
aziz de djeddah les fascias quercy